the National Basketball Association in
the US is seeing record numbers of men
joining cheerleading cheerleading squads
as some claim it's a response to the me2
movement to avoid any hint of sexism
though some cereal is aren't exactly
Dancing with the light the decision
feels like a slap in the face
we were always fighting our own
organization to get the credit attention
and respect that we deserved and in
hindsight they were already pushing us
out of the door now in the past year
eight out of the 30 NBA teams have
replaced all female dance squads with
mixed gender groups their claim it's to
diversify their entertainment programs
well women in NBA dance troupes say
they've experienced sexual harassment
and poor working conditions with some
only earning the minimum wage some claim
the decision to open up to all sexes
will reduce their career opportunities
further we spoke with a former National
Football League cheerleader who believes
there are better ways to promote
diversity in sport we don't have an
issue with co-ed teens it's fine to have
male and females dance together what we
think is in you know doesn't reflect
equality is the way that the decisions
were made where the women weren't
allowed to have their presence with the
dance team and have men be added to the
program as opposed to completely
disbanding their teams altogether and
the way that they were treated the lack
of respect in making the decisions
really doesn't reflect an equal playing
field at all for women dissolution for
these for the management should not have
been to eliminate them as a liability or
to try to fix their image by going this
family-friendly or gender inclusive
route that really was not the point of
that they should have been addressing
you